[Music]
so time for thursday's press preview
then we're taking a look at the front
pages of friday's papers time to see
what's making those headlines with the
columnist carol malone who's joined by
the editor of the courier in dundee
david clegg they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight very good
evening to both of you nice to see we'll
chat in a moment after we've taken a
look at some of those front pages
beginning with the telegraph which
understands the prime minister's advisor
on standards may resign over allegations
he was misled about who paid for
refurbishments to boris and carrie
johnson's flat
same story also on the front of
tomorrow's guardian
the metro suggests that the birth of the
johnson's new baby takes the prime
minister out of the firing line for now
but the eye indicates that the reprieve
may not last long with rishi sunak and
liz truss said to be considering
leadership challenges against mr johnson
the daily mail says that the prime
minister could face the back bench
revolt as up to 50 mps could vote
against new coronavirus restrictions
the times reports that the conservative
party have slumped to their worst poll
ratings in 11 months as the prime
minister battles on several fronts
here's the ft hearing treasury officials
are rebuffing pleas from business
leaders to reintroduce extra
dispensations for companies during plan
b restrictions
let's bring in david's paper the courier
reporting the scottish government has
urged people to delay christmas parties
until the omicron surge has passed
and the tools are alive with the sound
of music is the daily star's cheeky
headline pointing out how under new face
mask rules shoppers are allowed to
remove their masks and walk around a
store singing
without breaking the rules
and we're joined tonight by carol malone
and david clegg i wonder if that's the
sort of behavior they would uh undertake
uh perhaps we can find out in
the space of the next few minutes good
to see you both let's start with the
guardian uh shall we uh carol i mean it
is there's so many issues for the prime
minister at the moment it's almost hard
to keep across all of them plan b
parties payments and of course
parenthood but let's start with those
flat payments uh because boris johnson
apparently told his independent adviser
on standards that he knew nothing of the
payments he was cleared of any wrong
wrongdoing saying he didn't seem aware
of where the money came from but now
uh the electoral commission reports that
boris johnson sent this message to lord
brownlow last november asking for money
so where where do we stand carol
well because what that what all of this
does is kind of confirm what everybody
has been saying for a very long time now
that boris lies as easily as he breathes
you know this is the electoral
commission has now fined the tories uh
the tory party
hundred pounds because they found this
missing evidence about the fact that he
asked for this donation when he said he
hasn't and he's saying to boris you've
gotta explain to me
satisfactorily um why you were admitted
to tell me that because it makes him
look very stupid and he's supposed to be
you know an independent investigator so
yeah i mean boris is in trouble i mean
this just adds to his long list of woes
this week i think he's very it's very um
it's very appetizing he's very lucky
that his baby was born today uh because
it gets it does get about the firing
line that's one of the headlines in one
of the papers it gets him out of the way
for a week or so but it is not going to
stop this tory rebellion against the new
covert curves it is not going to stop uh
politician people in the tory party
looking at him and saying is this the
guy to lead us you know we've got some
very serious issues coming up next year
we've got the social care crisis we've
got the migrant crisis and this is a guy
who just seems to bring chaos wherever
he goes you know i've lost count now of
how many parties they're investigating
when i started reading at lunchtime it
was three it looks that the metro is
saying to that tonight it's gone up to
seven three separate investigations
on seven parties and and one of the some
of these investigations are being led by
i think we were told a top civil servant
but but it was one of these so-called
top civil servants says boris that told
him no parties had ever occurred so how
independent is all this gonna be but but
all it does is
it just muddies boris's name even more
than he was already so i think it's a
good it's a good thing he's actually
good
okay um uh david let's look at the front
of the daily telegraph same story there
little guy tom brink of quitting over
the prime minister's flat um we'll talk
more generally in a moment but first of
all on this specific issue um it is
complicated uh about who said what and
when do you think the public actually
care about about the wallpaper in the
johnson's flat
well or they're particularly interested
in that detail i think it adds to this
sense and there is definite cut through
in this in in that boris johnson is not
to be trusted that his word means
nothing
so
he he has his own standards advisor uh
considering his position because he
can't trust what boris johnson told him
about this situation about what he knew
about where this money was coming from
he's been fined by the elector or the
conservative party i should say have
been fined by the electoral commission
over this today which under normal
circumstances would would merit a lot of
coverage given the amount of
the amount of fronts that boris johnson
and the conservative party are fighting
on at the minute that has basically been
a throne a throwaway on par six of most
of the newspaper coverage uh tomorrow i
i think that what what we are seeing
here is
consequences beginning to flow boris
johnson throughout his entire
life actually has been someone who has
never really felt the consequences of
his actions and he has
came to believe that he operates in a
consequence-free environment so
it doesn't it doesn't matter what he
says as long as he gets to the next day
that he gets out of that scrape and what
he's finding is that when you're prime
minister eventually
these things can catch up with you so so
when your standards advisor is
threatening to quit when your party's
being fined with the electoral
commission
and before we even get into the whole
christmas party issue it just it just
feels to me that the house of cards is
tumbling so the details of the wallpaper
the detail of the refurbishment the
detail of where the exactly the money
came from that's probably not cutting
through with the public and they're not
interested in that but they are
interested in the fact that they're that
very few people have faith in the word
of their prime minister
yeah down the street saying the prime
minister wasn't aware of who was
providing the money only that lord
brownlow was overseeing it let's move on
to the front of the metro mum's the word
really going on what you were saying
carol that uh the birth of uh baby
daughter means that perhaps he's out of
uh out of hot water for a short while
at least um but talking about those
parties and you mentioned them at them
earlier carol and they're mentioned on
the front of the metro as well calls him
to quit um over the christmas party's
row etcetera and we're hearing tonight
that the director of communications uh
the very man that was advising the prime
ministers to say that no party had taken
place actually appears to have been at
one
yeah and not only that there are stories
that boris himself appeared at a party
it was a leaving speech around about
that time and he he he gave a speech
therefore whoever was was leaving and
this this kind of confirms you know what
david was just saying about the fact
that you know i did a tv show yesterday
and there was lots of call-ins from
people and and i realized i listened to
stories from people who
story after story from people who lost
people during covert you know children
who've lost parents vice versa parents
who've lost tiny children people who
weren't allowed to be at the birth of
their child people who had to put hands
on glass last christmas to to they
couldn't touch their loved ones but
that's all they could do they were kept
away they were locked out and and they
find that that you know people in
diamond street are having hoolis and
that was only one yesterday
and you know every single person who
came on those phones was crying and i i
was thinking this is so
damaging for boris above all the other
things that but i don't think anyone
gives the stuff about about the the
wallpaper he's flat but they do care
that they kept to the restrictions and
even though they did people they loved
died and here we have the people in
power laughing at us making fun of us
saying you know there's one rule for you
a lot of plebs and there's another rule
for the rest of us we're superior to you
and it is this shocking sense of
superiority i think that has cut people
to the bone and this by-election they're
going to have in north shropshire next
week would be a very good gauge i think
on how much this has hit home the
parties because although it sounds like
a party it's much much more it goes much
deeper than that
jack doyle thing is quite significant
because
because the the point there is that
there's this long-term uh lack of trust
in boris johnson and it's part of his
character is his is his personality you
know he's a he's a lovable rogue but if
jack doyle has been at one of these
parties and then the government's
communications which he runs has spent
the last 10 days almost saying that
there was no party that means that we
now have uh the government machine
funded by the taxpayer people who work
for us
engaging in deliberate deceit
now that is a very very significant
situation that cannot be allowed to
continue especially
if it is established that that is a fact
i think we're in a very grave situation
yeah yeah as we all know honestly one of
the seven key principles isn't it of
public life david we need to go to break
in a moment but i just want to bring in
the front of the eye tory leader
contenders circle a prime minister in
peril i mean next week looks very
dangerous doesn't it for the prime
minister around 50 mps we're hearing
planning tory mps planning to vote
against uh kovid measures and now
supporters of rishi sunak liz trust as
well sort of circling where do you think
this goes
i think it's a very dangerous moment for
boris johnson now obviously i'm in
dundeem in scotland and i've been
speaking to scottish conservatives who
it should be said uh have had their
problems with boris johnson in the past
and are not maybe his most loyal support
base but they are heart sick they are
humiliated they are at the end of their
teller they want rid of him immediately
so i think if that if any sense of that
is going out across the wider
conservative party he's got he's got
he's got big big problems and it's not a
surprise to see you know the very
ambitious chancellor rishi sunak
on maneuvers by the looks of it we're
told that liz trust the foreign
secretary has been uh having private
lunches with mps trying to gather
support
how could you not be looking at boris
johnson and the
media coverage he's endured for the last
week and be thinking anything other than
oh there could be an opportunity here so
i i think i think we will we will see
this continuing next week could be very
tricky for him we knew the covet
measures are uh very unpopular as well
and there's a very interesting line in
the telegraph actually which is saying
in an interview with the telegraph sir
here starmer the the labor leader has
called for these uh coveted rebels in
particular to act decisively to remove
him from office so so so there is this
this building momentum behind that i
think now boris johnson is um
he's very resilient so that could it
could all change but i think certainly
he's in it he's in a very dangerous spot
just very briefly one thought on this
yeah completely i think you know he's
been accused of bringing in these curves
to bury the bad news of what was going
on in down in the street and that alone
that other zone is sickening and i think
that's incredibly dangerous for him
all right uh thank you both uh for the
moment carolyn david speak to you again
in a moment because coming up
exactly when should you hold a delayed
christmas party we'll ponder on that and
other questions raised by all the caviar
restrictions
[Music]
oh again part two of the press preview
carolyn david still with us let's turn
to david because it's the front of his
paper the courier we're looking at next
and public health scotland david urging
christmas parties to be cancelled but of
course the prime minister said on
tuesday no we don't want people to
cancel such events
and the scottish government nicolas
sturgeon the deputy first minister here
john swinney had been saying the same
thing as well it wasn't until 5 pm
today that this statement came out
notably it wasn't a politician whose
name it was in i presume none of them
wanted to play the grinch it was dr nick
finn from public health scotland press
release drop saying that they're now
saying because of the spread of omnicron
the fact that it's being linked to
in particular a number of parties
there's just over 100 cases in scotland
have been identified so far that they
are recommending and this is not a legal
mandate it is only a recommendation and
recommendation they're encouraging
people to what they say in slightly
strange language to fair their christmas
party
which as you can imagine has provoked a
furious response in particular from the
hospitality industry in scotland who
obviously missed the christmas
period last year which is normally quite
lucrative and the there's there's
suggestions tonight that this could be
the final straw for lots of uh pubs
restaurants and other hospitality venues
that are are looking like they could be
facing a wave of cancellations tomorrow
yeah i mean what would be the response
if uh if they have to defer hogmany
parties i mean that would go down even
uh
even worse i would have thought um what
do you make of this carol because you're
shaking your head
i actually yeah i mean i am because i
think these i think these curves
were put in place we were told
a week ago that there would be no new
curbs before christmas possibly in
january
and here we go you know within 24 hours
of the christmas the christmas party
debacle they're here but you know not a
single person in 38 countries have died
from the from the omicron uh strain it
seems incredible to me that you know
it's wrong i agree with theresa may but
she said the other day in the comments
you just said you know we can't keep
locking down and imposing curbs every
time a new strain of this this virus
shows it's its face and you know we we
have a recovering economy and every time
we do this we set it into a tailspin
covert is never going to go away society
has to find a way to live we were told
by boris johnson himself last year that
the vaccines were going to be
the road back to normality and that road
was going to be irreversible and yet
here we are again this christmas doing
exactly what we did last christmas
they're not saying we absolutely can't
this time but they're saying we
shouldn't and the thing they know about
the british people they're very
responsible people they will they will
do what they think is right and they
will keep to the curbs but it's actually
just not fair this this strain we've
been told unless they've got some new
data in the last few hours it says
otherwise we're tilt this new strain is
very mild it's not killing people and
it's not hospitalizing people yeah and
yet we're again posing on people's
freedoms yeah um okay we must leave it
there uh we'll talk about singing in the
isles in tesco
shortly but for the moment david and
carol thanks both very much
indeed